welcome back to the David packman show I
am Faron cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David packman and if you
would like even more from me you can
follow me on Twitter Instagram Facebook
and tick tock on all of those platforms
I'm at fair and balanced you can also
follow my YouTube channels youtube.com
fahrenbalanced and of course the big one
youtube.com
the Ring of Fire
let's talk about some of the problems
facing Donald Trump's lawyers and no I'm
not talking about all the issues with
Joe takapina the issues that have come
up with Jim trustee the sanctions that
Alina Haba was hit with no I'm actually
going old school with Trump lawyers
Jenna Ellis the former Trump lawyer who
of course worked on efforts to overturn
the 2020 election for which she was also
punished in Colorado
this week she posted some screenshots
of uh messages that she has received in
messages that she has seen online from
Angry Maga fans
who are angry at her about something
that according to Jenna isn't even
happening
these attacks are disgustingly sexist
and crude but I'm going to read a couple
of them here
um these again these are the ones that
she posted uh first one of course was
from Laura Loomer who according to Raw
Story mocked her for being quote
disowned by Trump World and trying to
ingratiate herself with Ron desantis's
campaign by offering herself up as quote
sloppy seconds
Trump supporter Preston para took a
similar line of attack and accused her
of being a quote for hire escort for Ron
DeSantis
magafan Alex brucevicz referred to her
as quote jeba Ellis before going on to
describe her as a quote d-list reject
goon
so why are all of these hardcore Trump
fans mad at Jenna Ellis
for trying to get a job with Ron
DeSantis
well here's what Jenna Ellis had to say
about that she said I was called a lot
of things and had a lot of less leftist
hit pieces trying to destroy my
credibility while I represented Trump
but I never saw a media Outlet or
Journal use the blatant sexism and
vulgarity that Maga influencers do now
and I don't even work for DeSantis she
added
so Jenna Ellis of course has been the
target of you know liberal hit pieces as
she calls them there weren't hit pieces
they were you know talking about your
career and the things you were
attempting to do
now I'm one of those people
I went after Jenna Ellis plenty because
of course she was trying to overturn
a federal election here in the United
States that's definitely not something
that lawyers should be doing especially
based on the fact that all of the
evidence was total BS
never wants to launched a sexist attack
against her never got vulgar with her
just attacked her work
which is fair game
these attacks are disgusting I don't
care if Jenna Ellis is working for
Donald Trump I don't care if she's
working for Ron DeSantis these attacks
are gross and have no place in civilized
discourse here in the United States
especially when the thing they're
accusing her of isn't even a thing at
least not not as of right now
so what's happened
is these crazed Maga fans have created a
fantasy in their heads
right they've created this scenario
where suddenly somehow Jenna Ellis works
for Ron DeSantis
and then they got mad about the fantasy
they created and started attacking her
for doing a thing that they think she
did but she's like I'm not I'm not even
doing it
and honestly who cares if she does
she's not working for Donald Trump
anymore she is a free person in this
country allowed to do whatever the heck
she wants to do if Ron DeSantis wants to
hire her for his campaign as a legal
advisor for a lawyer he's allowed to do
that she's allowed to take it and you
don't get to launch these horrible
attacks against her
if you want to go after her record as a
lawyer if you want to you know critique
the things she says when she goes on you
know a conservative media do it
but once you start to get into that
realm of these disgusting horrendous
attacks that is crossing a line that
these Maga people seem to love to cross
Jenna Ellis was once their friend
but again because they've created this
weird fake scenario now they hate her
they're just going to launch all the
horrible attacks they can
because they think she's doing something
that would be very easy to verify if she
was doing right you you can check the
campaign records you you can check the
state records we do have open records
laws at least at the moment here in
Florida if she were working for Ron
DeSantis it would have to be reported
and you could look that up
but that's a little too much homework
for those Maga folks to do so they would
rather assume the worst
which how is that even the worst
she's not working for Trump she's got to
work somewhere you got to make money
right Republicans always tell you you
got to have a job you can't be a lazy
mooch
so
why are you begrudging somebody for
getting a job
none of it makes any sense
but then again nothing in mega world
makes any sense